- We are back.
(audience claps)
And when our next guest discovered
her son's drawing talent,
she wanted to foster that gift.
But, as she quickly realized,
access to the arts often
falls through the cracks.
So, she took action,
and now she's running
a thriving arts program
for all the kids in her
community, not just her son,
which is amazing, and that's
why we call her a rad human.
("Rad Human" theme music)
All right, everybody, from
Brooklyn's Red Hook Art Project,
also known as RAP, everybody
say hello to Tiffany.
(audience cheers)
So, we were.
- Hi, Kelly!
- Hello.
- How are you? Hi everyone.
- So, we were talking about your son.
You noticed he had, you know,
it was very talented art,
but you didn't really know
what to do with that, right?
- No.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I mean, my children
were always into the arts,
but as a young mom, giving
birth at the age of 14 years old
and not having access to the arts myself,
I just didn't understand.
For me, it was like,
"Son, daughter,
you need to know how to
read and do writing."
I didn't understand the whole.
- The basics.
- The basics. I just didn't,
it didn't resonate with me.
I just didn't, it wasn't until, you know,
he drawing on the walls.
I was like, "somebody's
trying to tell me something.
What do I need to do?"
- Yeah.
"And, first of all,
don't draw on my wall."
- Exactly. That part.
(audience laughs)
- But, art classes
weren't an option, right?
- No, art classes wasn't an option for me.
You know, living in
low income communities,
going to low income schools,
DOE making a lot of cuts,
funding, the first thing
they do is pull the arts.
- [Kelly] Arts, yeah.
- And, for me, that's another
way to silence a child,
another way of silencing a person
when they don't have
access to these things.
Some people are introverts,
they don't like to speak out loud, right?
- Yeah.
- So, they like to draw,
and paint a picture around
what they're trying to say,
you know?
So not having access to that
felt like death in itself.
- Yeah, no,
Arts is literally the reason
why I graduated high school,
'cause I had to make certain average
to be able to participate
in the art program.
- [Rad Human] Absolutely.
- So that was what really drove me,
'cause all of our brains
work differently, you know,
and how we learn.
So, where is Red Hook Art Project today?
- Right now, Red Hook
Art Project is an asset
in our community. We do a lot
of work in our communities.
We support students with
building art and music portfolios
so they can audition for
specialized high schools
and colleges.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- We also fight food
insecurities, you know,
just during the pandemic
we were able to put community
refrigerators outdoors,
and bring over like $1.2
million into the neighborhood
to make sure kids have access
to food, and also, I mean.
- [Kelly] (claps)God, wow.
- For art classes.
- That's incredible.
- Yeah.
- You're a great mama.
You're like a mama bear
taking care of all the kids.
- Yeah. It's important.
- Yeah.
- So, creative writing programs,
y'all do that as well, right?
- Yes.
Creative writing is a
huge part of our program,
because again, you can't make art,
and not be able to express
what it's about, right?
When you're curating your own art shows,
you have to be able to write about it,
write your descriptions,
write your medium.
You know, just write what it's about.
So, I think even in school,
when you're writing out your
essays to go to college,
you have to be able to do
creative writing, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- To be able to get these
scholarships and get these grants.
So, writing is a big part of what we do,
and it's songwriting.
Like, my daughter, she blossomed
through the organization
because she used music
and writing as a tool.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She graduated high school a year early,
and show her the tour,
and then went into cosmetology school.
- Whoa! Oh God.
- All because of her being
able to write and see herself.
- Honestly, that was me as a kid as well.
As soon as I started writing, and music,
it was therapeutic,
and it gave me a certain
level of confidence
that I could achieve anything.
I think I believe in that as well.
So, what do you feel like
your organization's impact
has been on the community?
- Our impact is ensuring that
students have a safe, vibrant
space to be, they have a voice,
that we meet each of
them where they're at,
and they have access.
The impact is access.
A lot of us, myself growing
up, didn't have that,
or didn't even understand
what access or resource meant.
So, I think the impact is
meeting people where they're at
and giving them that
access that they deserve.
We all want the same thing.
- [Kelly] Opportunity.
- Opportunities, and a safe place to be.
- Yeah. You want to be
successful, whatever that means.
- Absolutely.
- For you and your children.
Yeah, absolutely. Well, we
love your passion for the kids.
Like, not just your kids,
but like other kids.
That's incredible. That's
what makes you so rad.
Red Hook, and for the arts,
we love what y'all are doing
for the arts in general,
and so does our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of friction the
go-to reasonable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
And, they want to celebrate
those creating fearlessly
just like you, so they're
gonna give Red Hook Art Project
$5,000.
- Wow.
(audience cheers)
- And, I think it's so
important what you're doing.
And, I am from a similar neighborhood,
like, before I moved,
like, even to Burleson,
like, I'm from Fort Worth, Texas as well.
And, I'm from the same neighborhood.
We did not have opportunity as well.
So, I now have the means to
help out kids that were me.
So, I'm gonna give you $5,000
as well, so that's 10,000,
because this is helping
out me as a kid too.
I think it's really
cool what you're doing.
It's really special, and
setting them up for success
to give them that edge is amazing.